all right they say don't mess with texas
but the mayor of austin texas is saying
that the governor there shouldn't be
messing with masks in texas that uh
giving away and ending all restrictions
in the state
including a mask mandate come next week
that is going a bit too far steve adler
is his name the austin texas mayor kind
enough to join us
right now mayor good to see you good to
see you neil now
um i i i think you're open to using some
of these restrictions but the mask was a
was a big you know a big line uh is that
about right
yeah i think that that's absolutely true
you know the
wearing mask doesn't doesn't slow down
opening up businesses
it doesn't uh slow down getting more and
more children in school in person
uh the the health folks here in
in texas seem to be pretty unanimous
that wearing masks help
and and helps minimize the risk that
we're not going to be able to open up
schools or open up businesses
we wouldn't put those things at risk and
i'm disappointed that
the the mandate's been withdrawn now our
governor has said that it's still
important to wear masks and
and i appreciate that but by removing
the the the mandate
i think we create an ambiguity there are
many people in the state that are
hearing that
as a message that masking doesn't work
it's not effective or that we're past
uh concern on the virus and that
ambiguity and communication
is what i have the the biggest issue
with
well you know he did leave it with
businesses and localities to decide
what and how they saw fit a number of
businesses to your point mayor
are going to insist on that i think
kohl's and some other
big retailers are saying in their stores
masks on
um is that not good
and no no no and i appreciate that and
i'm real supportive and
of the businesses and trying to hold
them up and and elevate them the ones
that are doing that
but there are others that have removed
the mandate in their stores because they
they felt comfortable uh insisting that
everybody wear masks when it was part of
a mandate
and with the mandate gone they they
don't feel like they are
empowered to do that or don't want to
deal with with customers that are coming
in that don't want to wear masks
uh so it's so it's good it's better than
than not and i appreciate the businesses
that are doing it but the
but the consistency of the message which
is
we are not out of the pandemic yet if we
can hold on a little bit longer we're
vaccinating more and more people
it is just not something that that we
have to add any question or doubt about
and put at risk opening up our schools
and opening up businesses
mayor i'm curious what you made of the
president's response to all of this
it raised some eyebrows when he talked
about what's going on in texas and
mississippi where you react to this as
the president on this development
the last thing we need is neanderthal
thinking that in the meantime
everything's fine take off your mask
forget it it still matters
you know a lot of your fellow texans
mayor
kind of blanched at that what do you
mean neanderthal that it was a put down
of texans
do you know right i i
that we are politicizing the wearing of
masks
is is part of the problem i think that
we're we're facing as a country i just
wish it wasn't
caught up in the politics at all most of
if not the overwhelming majority if not
almost
every health expert says that wearing
masks
help and and i would always err
on the on the side of of of that
when it is entirely consistent with
opening up businesses
and schools so so yes i i i the
neanderthal
comment was more the point mayor the
natural do you think the
the president should not have used that
that term because many took it that way
like wow are we provincial idiots here
well you know i don't think that i take
it personally and certainly it was a
strong word and it got a lot of
attention
uh i wish would you have used it would
you have used a word like that
not a word that i have used but i have
been really hard and real insistent that
the mandate shouldn't have gone away
we try to be guided by the science of
the data and removing the mandate is not
being guided
by the science and the data so whatever
you want to call it it's the wrong move
um well i have you here mayor uh there's
been a concern about
what's going on the border now some
might disagree whether it's a crisis but
100 000 migrants suddenly at the border
in february the highest we've seen
a couple of years some are interpreting
it as
open season that the president himself
has sort of triggered
by making the comments he has by uh
putting a freeze on deportations but not
building more of the wall by looking at
a kinder gentler way as he puts it to
deal with migrants and migrant minors
many of whom he wants to put in in
facilities u.s military facilities
to protect them while we're going
through this process of
of of dealing with them uh do you think
a it's a crisis
and b do you think if it is the
president has made it that way
you know i'm i'm a supporter of of of
of president bush's attempt to to come
up with a more comprehensive plan
for how we deal with immigration i think
we're going to run into problems
whenever we're trying to deal with this
issue in an ad hoc basis or just
one piece of it i i am in favor
of the of the the movement which i think
would be bipartisan if we could ever get
to the floor
uh in congress to have a more holistic
look at
at our immigration policy uh and
and that's the direction that uh i hope
the country is moving right now
mayor thank you very much for taking the
time on saturday we appreciate it sir
steve adler
uh the mayor of austin texas also what a
beautiful city beautiful city i